then screen junkies studios in the heart
of Los Angeles this is screen junkies
movie finds now your host Andy signor
today's episode is brought to you by
America's best unlimited network don't
miss a show with unlimited data from
t-mobile hello and welcome to movie
fights live I'm so excited be back I
have been held a beer foil and I gotta
think this man right here it brought him
back because he did such a wonderful job
in my chair last oh man I'll have Nick
round of applause because you crushed it
no you don't have to get a new job
because you have yours back oh yeah no
no but I had a blast thank you you made
me very nervous cuz you were fantastic
and thank you for stepping in there was
a lot of fun to watch I'm doing it it's
hard isn't it yeah like I mean people
give you crap because you always say oh
this is tough every one of those
decisions with stuff yeah you got to
sort of figure out a reason yeah you got
to figure you got to navigate you gotta
weigh pros and cons checks and balances
but we made it through welcome back
you'll be fighting you know how screen
junkies show so excited to have you back
here doing the fighting oh heck yeah
we're gonna be doing some other I'm
about to introduce too but I want to
make sure I tease what we're fighting
this week is we got some fun stuff I got
best movie of the summer we got who's
gonna be the next Joker the potential
standalone movie that they said there's
like eight move Joker movies apparently
happening we want to pitch the job of
the hut standalone movie and we want to
see which Marvel defender would make the
best standalone film so there's a lot of
fun stuff stay tuned you can always join
the conversation live on Twitter hashtag
movie fights live so join Dan they're
following the the feed but here's who's
fight today aside from Hal Rudnick who I
introduced
he's the writer one of the writers of
honest trailers and you see him on
screen junkies every day pretty much
it's Joe star welcome back Joe I'm so
excited to fight some more I know it's
been a while yes yeah it's been a little
while I've never fought
either of these gentlemen about movies
yeah so this will be great I'm excited
we've done some fist fighting we in real
life yeah the two of we've scrapped a
little bit one gram easily he just broke
the first rule of our fist fighting
clubs oh great oh it's right on the
the cage well the victor apparently in
that Fight Club was Graham Elwood
welcome back Graham comedy film nerds
they can listen to you and your new
documentary earbuds the podcasting
documentary tell us working together
that'll be you can pre-order on iTunes
right now it'll be available September
12th iTunes Google DirecTV everywhere so
very proud of that movie and then of
course you can listen to comedy film
rants calm we're not as fighty on comedy
film just talking about yeah we just
hope I can hug it out yeah we can
aggressive some people like the one you
guys get aggressive and talk over each
other and then others don't
it's that's why I like to mix it up yeah
some episodes are for some people that I
can't tell what they want why are you
guys so chill we don't know but I do
want to give how predicates credit cuz
he's had to step in late we had Perry
we're trying to it back in the show and
she had she had something she couldn't
get out of and we totally understood I'm
hoping to get you back Perry thank you
for turning in but how kudos and we make
sure people know you can't you had to
come in last minute so you have a little
bit of a disadvantage there thank you
for that preface but you know I looked
up in the sky and there was the movie
fight symbol in the air and so I called
a neighbor heard the conch shell
fittings I wanted to reward you for last
week you were such a good job so thank
you for coming back now and now if you
get to double duty back hard one do so
let's see if you can put the fighting
cap back off then take the judge hat off
here we go Dan Majerle you'll be helping
us dad how's it going over there
hi this might be the first time I've
been over your fact-checking sis we look
live yeah I mean the first time I'm here
live on YouTube this is great it's crazy
yeah probably what are they like in the
feeds there I'm looking at the feeds
it's impossible to read the YouTube that
means they're dirt and they're all
watching so it's get they're watching on
Twitter I got hash tag what we fight
slave I got that uh public fact-checking
as always should be a very good show
three great competitors and getting back
into the groove of things I feel like
since comic-con it's just been craziness
Dan I heard you might be fighting next
week as your first fighter as non champ
I heard that too official fighting that
coming area anxious to get back in the
ring and start fighting seeing you very
fight a lot but they're gonna see you
fight heavy lies the head but now I
don't have that
I lost chuckling before halfway through
all right well I'm excited to watch that
next week and I'm excited to watch this
week right now let's do it you guys know
the rules you're all veterans let's get
to it
[Applause]
that 10 fights
oh right round one this one came in from
Crispin artists on Twitter
he wants to know what was the overall
best movie of summer 2017 there were a
lot of movies that came out Joe what was
the best the best movie to me summer
2017 is one that reminded me of summer
movies when we were kids remember before
the Internet where you knew a movie was
gonna come out and you just were stoked
about it for months and months and
months then it came out and it felt like
an event felt like a big deal that you
got to go see it that movie for me this
summer was Wonder Woman we've been we
the billed to Wonder Woman was loud and
fun and boisterous and it finally felt
like this big end destination where oh
god finally Wonder Woman is here we get
to go and it lived up to the hype and
more it was fun it had such an amazing
cast it had a great message to it the
action was fantastic it was such a
relief to see DC like get back on track
before they greenlit 19 Joker movies and
just just a fun movie I didn't see
anyone walk out a Wonder Woman
disappointed maybe people went it was
pretty good but I'll take pretty good
too
that movie was fantastic any day that's
a that's a good window to have kids
walking out with one woman tiaras on
little boys want to be Chris Pine little
boys wanting to be Wonder Woman little
girls wanting to be Chris Pine little
girls wanted to be Wonder Woman that was
a great summer movie all right Howard
you pickin well for my money the best
movie this summer is spider-man
homecoming
spider-man homecoming had I'll tell you
what this movie had a lot goin up
against it because there were good
superhero movies leading up to it you
had guardians you had Wonder Woman but
then also it had the stigma of like okay
in our lifetime how many spider-man's
have we seen and will we see but this
movie cut through all the crap with
several important factors just leading
the charge it was funny it was
action-packed it had one of the best
Marvel villains we have seen yet with
Michael Keaton's vulture and spider-man
homecoming surprised the hell out of
and it is my favorite movie of the
summer the best movie of the summer all
right
Graham I want with Dunkirk the reason I
went with Dunkirk
I love the superhero movies I'm a huge
fan of them but Dunkirk to me first of
all very bold choice for Christopher
Nolan and the studio to release this in
the summer in the middle of superhero
time because this is an Oscar film it to
me was one of the most poignant movies
about war that I've ever seen
I was gripping my seat for the entire
two hours and it was it was viscerally
it put me in the in the boots of the
soldiers on the ground it put me in the
airplane and it put me on the ship and
it was unbelievable and it's a big Oscar
movie to come out in the middle of the
summer all right guys now find out and
tell me why yours you think really will
be defined as the best movie of the
summer of 2017
no even as a war movie I almost felt
like Wonder Woman is a better war film
than Dunkirk what Dunkirk was missing
well it was a fantastic sort of
intellectual exercise in a war movie
it was missing those characters that we
can hang on to Black Hawk Down had those
Saving Private Ryan had those Wonder
Woman provided us with these
point-of-view characters that weren't
just sort of like composites entering a
war situation they they had arcs they
had needs they you know we cared about
them as they were going through these
trenches and Dunkirk lacked that it was
it was a very cold approach towards an
interesting sort of historical exercise
but it didn't give you the emotional
resonance that that woman had I'll
double down on that and say Dunkirk was
an immersive experience but it didn't
have all of the elements that say
spider-man homecoming had the the humor
the action the that combination that's a
heck of a KFC chicken sandwich buddy
down nice double down how here's the
thing three all the reasons you just
stated you didn't like Dunkirk or why I
think it is one of the most transcendent
war movies ever made because it
I was the soldier and I don't need
flashback of my girlfriend back in
England I gotta get back to her it was
like this is what real war is like the
Germans are coming you're gonna get
blown off this bridge you're gonna die I
don't need character arc it's real
simple get home that's it there is one
goal and that is to survive this war we
also world war 2 there so depicted as
the big heroes and then we saw what it
actually was young guys kids scared
shitless but I'm gonna pick up a fake a
stretcher with a guy and just fake my
way to get on this goddamn boat cuz I
want the hell out of here I didn't need
to know anything else other than I was
so immersed in this and I love the to
the movies you guys picked her great but
like the Wonder Woman ending it took me
out of it there's a lot of great
elements to Wonder Woman and it does
talk about war but to me Dunkirk any
young any 18 year olds like I want to
join the war and go to Afghanistan I go
watch Dunkirk and tell me how exciting
it is Wonder Woman is like a is like a
propaganda movie to get young girls to
join the Marines I would contend I've
never but I would contend that Wonder
Woman is a good superhero movie and
because of the elements you know it
coming in to somewhat save DC or raise
the level of the recent crop of DC films
and it being one of the first strong
female lead superhero movies those I
feel like those elements falsely lift
people's perception of that movie I
would say the Wonder Woman is about the
quality of the first Captain America I
don't think it's a false lift at all i
those those L if something connects with
you in a movie that's not a false
elevation where a Spider Man spider-man
was another Marvel movie I walked out of
Spider Man kind of the same way I walked
out of guardians to where I was like
cool they're still making pretty good
they're still make a pretty good
spider-man again his friend who was
wanted to build the Lego Death Star with
him and everything I don't know the
actor's name but has there ever been a
like just a funnier more natural honest
like human character the characters in
this film his all of his classmates we
haven't
that kind of humor and this and the
innocence of these type of characters
and guardians of the galaxy to sort of
joke factoring there so here's something
with spider-man there was nothing when I
walked out of spider-man I would there
was no scene where I was like man I
won't forget that one whereas one woman
has the trench scene it's got the town
run that ends with the tank getting
flipped
I won't rewatch either of these movies
the way I would watch Wonder Woman like
oh that summer 17 wonderful movie I
won't watch Dunkirk because why would I
want a wild on a smaller screen and I
won't worry about spider-man because it
didn't really bring anything new tonight
like I feel like I got I got to address
the spider-man spy on his box
spider-man no spider-man movie because I
had a similar reaction that Joe had
which is cool
great Marvel man they know how to get it
get it done but I wasn't like wow
Wonder Woman had some of those elements
in terms of wow look at how they're
depicting like I would go I would put
Dunkirk in the one spot obviously and
then I would put Wonder Woman ahead of
spider-man because we're just calling it
that from now on can we make an
agreement on Tuesday I suspect so I
would just say because Wonder Woman did
some transcendent things in terms of
we've never seen a female superhero be
depicted that way I was like wow that's
cool but then to me as I said it fell
into a lot of cliche stuff at the end
with the big bad villain on it it missed
an opportunity to be transcendent
whereas Dunkirk is going to get a Best
Picture nomination so if you want to
talk about the best movie of the summer
it's one of the top end the movies of
the year that's why I would give it to
dunker I mean when we go into Award
nomination arguments I will remind you
that crash won an Academy Award for Best
Picture you know just just to throw that
out there as far as like Cousin Vinny
urge every award I want you to use this
as your finals why you use your little
thoughts here but why why isn't the most
definitive summer movie the best one of
the year okay you know Graham brought a
Olin intellectual film school exercise
to a comic book movie fight I think
and while Dunkirk was interesting it it
didn't get because I would argue if this
was a what's the best war movie question
I would argue that Saving Private Ryan
also gave you the the things that you
were talking about in Dunkirk the the
realism of war the the the people that
are on Normandy just trying to survive
but it still gave you the the emotional
entry point of Tom Hanks's character and
the talking dog whereas so between like
spider-man and Wonder Woman these are
both you know comic book movies have all
sort of hit their stride where from beep
to beat in most comic book movies now we
can kind of go okay I see what's coming
I see what's coming but Wonder Woman by
a twist that you guys are sort of trying
to minimize just by you know the casting
and and this this character and a female
director and patty Jenkins just by
giving this movie a slightly different
POV much in the same way that master of
none just by giving it a slightly
different POV of Aziz Ansari's point of
view makes it feel so much more than
just a standard Judd Apatow feeling TV
show does that make sense like Wonder
Woman just elevates so much further it
had scenes that won't leave you where a
Spider Man I had a hard time remembering
scenes from spider-man once you sort of
swing seen him swing around you've seen
him swing around in all of his movies
but we've seen Wonder Woman once we've
seen her get out of that trench once
that's such an iconic moment how final
thoughts Spider Man was filled with
memorable scenes and and let's start
with Michael Keaton he's he may be the
best villain we've seen in any Marvel
movie thus far Marvel who's seriously
lacking in strong heavies for their
films that scene where he's talking to
food alert
yeah spoiler alert that scene where he's
talking to Peter Parker in the backseat
of that car after dropping him off for
the prom I'm never gonna forget that
scene that's one of the great
conversational scenes between a villain
and a hero I've seen in any Marvel film
that Washington Monument scene where
spider-man saves everybody I found a
Wonder Woman to be a good movie I
thought spider-man that we've never had
the combination of humor and
action in marvel that I feel at
spider-man has to I mean just the
humanity of Peter Parker Tom Holland
became the best spider-man he had so
much going up against him and in face of
those incredible odds going up against
Sam Raimi and the rest of the Marvel
Universe as as well this film became the
I would say the definitive spider-man
movie it's the best spider-man movie
better than spider-man 2 and yeah it had
such humanity that and it haunts me to
this day I will say this you talked
about one of the best villains of all
time a Dunkirk added the Nazis are the
best villain of all time and there still
are so the thing about this is you made
the comparison Joe to Saving Private
Ryan the thing that I thought Saving
Private Ryan will be out there and one
of the top war movies of all time it did
get there and there's some wonderful
moments obviously what I loved about
Dunkirk is he went I don't need I don't
need stories about my wife when I was a
teacher on which were fine but there
were some moments like earn this the
ending of saving primer I was like aw
come on man spoiler alert
you know I'm like I don't need you to
tell beat me over the head hey war it's
painful and you made it I we know that
we know how awful war is we know how
awful World War 2 was and you want to
talk about the best acting I've ever
seen is literally the just the eyes once
again the best mask actor in the planet
is prom hardy you just see his eyes and
the blade you go for Grammy don't worry
you're gonna do
take control Nazis take control of your
Dunkirk Beach so like it was fantastic
in terms of so much emotion was conveyed
with very little dialogue very little
backstory but it was all on the screen
it was all understood and years from now
will I remember Wonder Woman and
spider-man yeah but they'll be in the
mass heap of all of the good superhero
movies I'll put them in my top ten or
whatever but Dunkirk is gonna be like
there's three like it's one of the best
war movies I have ever seen and
therefore it transcends everything that
came out this summer and this year all
right Dan there's a little card up in
the corner screen car in the right side
of YouTube house spider-man's friend was
Ned he's played by actor Jacob battle on
thank you sir spider-man's best friend
most of the conversation both on Twitter
and from what I could see of the YouTube
feed people endorsing other movies Lee
and summers voted for girls trip just
for Baker said winDriver Ashley Davis
thought it was atomic blonde Eric voted
for War of the Planet of the Apes one
that I would throw in there that I
really loved was the big stick but the
overwhelming favorite that a lot of
people mentioned that nobody here picked
was baby driver many many many people
saying they thought that was their
favorite movie of the summer so I would
say that is the fan favorite of the ones
that aren't picked but a pretty vigorous
debate amongst everyone's selection so
I'm looking at the poll it's very close
not a fan favorite emerging quite yet Oh
interesting very close very close
argument yeah I mean this was a tough
one to listen to use because they all I
think all have great you know great
films for various different reasons but
based on your arguments I was just
trying to go back to who left who made
the points and who combated the points
the best
I loved pork the Wonder Woman is a
propaganda film for women to join the
Navy and didn't see it that way but I'm
hey I might be inspired to go
and a Marine Corps ad before my movie
Amazon with a woman yeah all right well
I love the lie don't know if that's a
bad day I mean what it's not it's
interesting it's a good to take I think
Joe got you burned though more but just
like I want well has the warm has it's a
good war movie Wonder Woman surprisingly
and it has you know characters to hang
on to as you said helped me you also I
feel like we're able to combat sort of
all crashes won an Oscar so the awards
go either way
and I did like your when how how pretty
much was just focusing on the comedy and
we haven't seen it before but then we
sort of he called you up we have seen it
in guardians and things so I think Joe
had the best counter-attacks there I got
to give Joe the first point for Wonder
Woman Dan what do you think when they
say it's so close I'm gonna reload it
one last time to see what this says this
is literally suspense 36 to 35% Joe also
won the Dunkirk with 35% how 27% and
those results they but they change the
entire fight so those may flip while I'm
talking to you all right look you an
island I do want to get in a strong
fight an honorary point to Graham for
bein yelling I've secured your dunkers
good alright Ron to kiss my cousin from
Amon RR ghio who wants to know who
should play the next Joker this is
actually a rematch for episode 3 dan can
you believe how long ago was that was
passed now that that we're up to reboot
and doing another Joker already so it's
time to bring this close back note we
think you know this should be part of
this rumored origins standalone that
they're talking about from potentially
um let's talk about who would be the
next new Joker how it's your turn to go
first who are you casting his Joker
gotcha so I want to go with an actor who
he hasn't like saturated us with his
performances and we like we're not going
to just like oh we know we're gonna get
out of this actor I want someone who's
gonna be a little bit unpredictable but
who's got a track record who's proven
that he could be that wild card that he
could be that chaotic madman that the
Joker is and I'm picking Dan Stevens
dan Stephens has proven to be a great
actor time and time again I mean in
Downton Abbey and Legion and the but the
movie the role that puts him over the
top as the Joker for me is this it's a
smaller film called the guest and he is
an intense maniac and just the mania
grows and expands throughout that movie
and that performance it's just haunting
and weird and he would be bring that
haunting weirdness to the Joker and make
it his own
alright gran what are you picking Dan
Stevens fine actor too pretty The Joker
needs to look insane and I'm not just
going off of the Heath Ledger my face
got cut up thing but the Joker needs to
physically look and yeah you could say
that kid dude they could do prosthetics
with Dan Stevens but he physically needs
to look like he's off he's a guy that if
you saw him walk down the street you'd
go what the [ __ ] you know what I mean
and I think that's why I go Paul Dano
Paul Dano can play someone who when he
comes on-screen you go this guy's off
this guy creeps me out this guy can take
he'll be able to take all of the history
of the Joker and again you are going up
against one of the best Joker
performances ever in Heath Ledger in my
opinion and you have to how can you make
anything better than that how can you
make it more unique and I go Paul Dano
because his body of work has been so
interesting so unique so sometimes he's
adorable sometimes he's creepy that is
the the the scariness of the Joker is
how he can be like fun-loving but he's
evil and sinister and is always addicted
to the insanity of life he loves the
fact that by maybe you are gonna kill me
today and he's always taunting Batman to
go against Batman's cardinal rule which
is I will not kill people and that has
been that in the dark graphic novels
Batman's like the final the one time I'm
gonna go against this is to kill the
Joker I should have done this years ago
so the Joker torments the Batman and you
need an actor like Paul Dano physically
looks like him and can emotionally and
mentally play the the subtleties of the
degrees of the Joker's insanity all
right Joe who you pickin okay so I do
agree that the Joker should not be a
handsome looking man like handsome Dan
sorry I just remembered Wayne's robe and
I agree with you he does need to look
kind of off he does need to be
extraordinarily creepy and more than
that to me
he needs to be unexpected Marvel used to
be our casting studio where we were like
surprised and interesting in the in
their casting like Chris Evans as
Captain America cool Robert Downey jr.
is Tony Stark cool and now they've
started to fall off and it they're
getting kind of predictable Benedict
Cumberbatch is Doctor Strange like whoa
that's some 90s obvious wizard magazine
casting to me and so now I want DC to
take over as the guys that do weird
casting and that is why I am picking
Marc Maron stand-up comedian Marc Maron
from glow from IFC's Maron and front of
the WTF podcast I'm going Marc Maron
guys the most accepted Joker origin well
oak sorry I guess I'll uh no pitting
statement and I'll just I'll just do
some arguing go for it okay most
acceptable joke or origin is the is he's
this the failing stand-up comedian he's
trying to provide for his family all it
takes is one bad day guys Marc Maron is
literally that Marc Maron was a stand-up
comedian that couldn't make it couldn't
make it couldn't make it it broke him it
legitimately broke him there was some
dark dark [ __ ] in Marc Maron that's why
he literally has a podcast where he just
apologizes to friends that he burnt he's
so he's so close to the lid to have just
becoming the Joker on his own he was one
mob offer I think in real life from
actually becoming the Joker
and I just think there's so much
darkness in this dude I think if you put
them with the right director and pulled
it out of him you get something really
special the same way you've got
something really special with heats what
Heath Ledger's Joker alright
ai-ai-ai-aight first of all it's a Marc
Maron I know Marv
and and his podcast will be in the los
angeles podcast festival october 6th to
the 8th and where the producers so he's
a fantastic he's the man he's and and i
love what you said about he's a comedian
but it's it's a little bit of a myth
that he was dead he had nothing he was
nowhere and his career was over he had
been on Conan O'Brien than anybody he
was a headlining tour in combat he's
living on the road he wasn't living
eating cat food in the back of his
career some errands Joker
oh my back I don't want to fight Batman
today get me a diet coke my foot hurts
I'm not gonna climb a thing you want me
to climb a thing if Mark K Mead said
I've a sinister probably mark come on
buddy no wrestling show and he's
completely inert he does not show anyone
look this guy he said there's some dark
[ __ ] in Marc Maron I figured but not
scary or threatening he is not scary or
threatening in any way Paul Danner
absolutely think he could be paul dano
was sitting in that chair right now just
watching us I would [ __ ] be crank the
[ __ ] out okay here's the thing with Paul
Dano it's called - Joker not the mope er
okay every movie he's in he does not
have the wild energy to play the Joker
in a minute and you say I'm Dan Stevens
is too handsome Heath Ledger what's the
most handsome guy in Hollywood when he
played the Joker but Heath Ledger had
some darkness to him Dan Stephen I don't
think does Dan Stevens can be directed
to you I own him obvious but I haven't
seen the guest because
I guess and I loved it but again it
wasn't the Joker is next level villain
you're doing if you want to cast Dan
Stephen as a villain sure he could
probably die save his Batman right
exactly but the Joker is the next he is
one of the best ever written villains in
anything ever you know what I don't of
him is so critical and it's what makes
the Dark Knight film so great and why
Paul Dano is weak you got him you get
him like agitated and crazy he's not
gonna be moping he's gonna hook your
skeezy I see Dan Stevens as a good
enough actor to go there to take the
mania and the chaos of the Joker where
it needs to go that's like a country
club kid that didn't get his dad's
products why it's going to be so much on
it so much more unexpected and he's
going to be able to play these different
flavors of the Joker he's going to be
able to cajole he's going to be able to
go and say when you bring up the guest
the guest is more like the t1000 he's
more just sort of this like terminator
but let me let me talk a little bit on
Paul Dano let me KFC chicken sandwich
this thing I don't like Paul Dano is a
joker because he's definitely on some
studio shortlist to play the Joker
already if you if you tomorrow to be
like Paul Dano is gonna play Joker and
eight of these Joker films I'd be like I
figured give us give us something weird
if we're gonna keep cranking Joker
movies out until the Sun [ __ ]
explodes
give me something weird that's why I
want I want this creepy failed broken
stand-up comedian to just open up and
give you some really dirt because maybe
when they get to the third or fourth one
I mean I love Marc but I mean he's
already too old yeah origins why dojo
the Joker doesn't do karate fights the
Joker manipulate didn't say it so Chris
an action see Ron and and to depict
Joker as a fighter he doesn't do fists
by I'm not talking about mobility I'm
talking about the Joker needs to be mid
30s he's gone through some crazy
horrible [ __ ] and you know how the Joker
is you don't know anything about the
Joker that's why I but I would
automatically know looking at Marc
Maron's that he is too old I would see
him on camera you can dress him up I was
Nicholson when he was the Joker and he
was he was not a great Joker in mind
that wasn't it was good it was a
different Joker but he was a fun Joker
well you're knock against against Dan
Stevens
is that this actor won't be able to do
the act that's he would be able to
immerse himself in that part he would be
able to get his hands dirty and play
that gritty type of character Dan
Stevens is great in the legion because
he has a supporting cast in a director
and a concept that are elevating him I
don't think he elevates that material
and I think with the Joker you need
someone who's going to bring something
new to the table and you know just
something sort of weird and off to the
table last thoughts okay look at Paul
Danos body of work he has already proven
that he has the one in the widest range
of actors he can pull off so much he is
the right age he's tall and lanky he's
the right body type he has the right
physicality and the right acting
abilities and I to me I envision him as
the Joker who was as I said one of the
most complicated and and best villains
we've ever seen and not just anyone can
play them I think one my final thought
is comedians are dark that is why Robin
Williams surprised everyone when he did
like insomnia when he did what was his
other one hour one hour photo thank you
that's why everyone went oh my god
that's in Robin Williams I promise you
that's in Marc Maron he's a stand-up
comedian we're all bred from the same
ilk we're all a little broken and all it
takes is one bad day and I think one
good director to really pull that out of
him and really surprise people if I lose
today I'm going to lose my [ __ ] so
that's just so you guys have one more
time come on bad day anga one one more
time here's Marc Maron as the Joker and
blow up Gotham I'd rather eat some soup
I gotta get to this post tomates I gotta
get some soup my cats I love my cats Dan
Stevens this in a joker origin story he
is the one who can make the greatest
transformation going from this more
clean-cut character who gets broken and
then incites the violence and brings the
chaos and the mania I think he's shown
us in he stands out in every part he
plays and he'd be fantastic
all right Stan the question is brought
up how old was Jack Nicholson where he
was the Joker he was 52 years old Mark
Maret is currently 53 years old so he's
right he's right there perfect days they
get a load of myself hey Batman are we
good are we good nice as you can imagine
there were many many suggestions for
from our fans for the role but there
were four that record the most the two
most popular were Willem Dafoe and Jake
Gyllenhaal will Poulter whom we used to
derogative please refer as I browse gift
for the baserunner he's actually really
good at Detroit's I have retired calling
him eyebrows kid hope altar was a very
popular choice another very popular
choice and someone who has tackled the
dare I say it
iconic role before Hal Rudnick mmm-hmm
played the Joker for us till they get a
load of me very very popular choice I'm
looking at the pole I think for once we
have some agreement but I will let you
make your decision a day and they'll see
how these poles [ __ ] go
yeah look I applaud you Joe for the marc
maron take and you gave me a really good
you did give me a surprisingly good
argument but then I just had this
trouble if they didn't like you do see
him as sort of old how did do good voice
he's a good voice and yeah we don't see
the range to get past that look cuz he's
a comedian not an actor Robin Williams
was both so I think that their their
attack on that which definitely didn't
hurt help but very close it came down
though for me between Dan Stevens and
Paul Dano and I just got a little more
to Graham particularly I liked when you
were like if he was just stand sitting
there right now he would be freaked out
by him and I just that's very true I
think he would just look at us very it
would be a silently and pause be
off-putting and it's not maybe the most
obvious answer but I think you did a
really good job as to what what the
character requires needs to be off
unique and all these things you listed
sinister and I just think he has that an
incident in spades so Graham gets the
second Bell our Twitter
hold both also compare with that paul
dano winning fairly handily in both
polls Wow come on I'm apparently better
know how to judge a little bit thank you
what a three-date bet they tell me when
I'm at I don't have time here's a very
old reference book em Danno for the part
of the Joker Oh Gary you're like doing
ah there's no fur where is an executive
that wants to do that
yeah if you tuned in for 1950s TV
references alright here we go this
should be fun question 3 hi there's talk
of a standalone Jabba the Hutt movie
guys who's excited okay let's get
excited we want to hear you guys pitch
top of the hat standalone movie and
grandeur first this time tell us your
vision for the Jabba the Hutt movie
Jabba the Hutt origin story
I got a skinny calling out give a title
Jabba origins or you can't get Jabba the
skinny beginning okay he starts out he's
skinny he's lean he's trying he's
growing up in the crazy sand planet he's
trying to get things figured out and
then he kind of has some sort of a
little bit Joker esque bad events that
happened to where he loses we see he
loses his his family he loses his
ability and slowly has to kind of
because he's let's be honest he's not
full dark side but he ain't on the side
of the Jedi he's not the side of the
force so he you see him you know just
part of it is I just got to survive so
how do I survive well I got to become a
crazy traitor I got a do this and get
into that and he he makes some you see
him sort of it's almost like better call
Saul but you better call Saul isn't
great it's like that you're seeing the
dilemma of well I want to do the right
thing but I can't I gotta feed my family
I got to pay you know and then and then
oh I got a you know feed this crazy worm
that lives in the sand that devours
people for a thousand years you know and
so I'm gonna start getting into that and
no I don't want to do you know sexual
slaves slavery but this girls
and I can make somebody you don't like
and just slowly get that and then as you
know and he's not taking care of himself
and starting to put on a little bit of
weight as we get into it and then we
that's where we see this as a three part
origin story to get us to the job that
we saw in Jedi three parts yes okay
Dublin triple n down welcome Dan okay
this chicken sandwich will be nothing
but chicken breasts even the lettuce
will be chicken breast uh my movies
called scum and villainy mmm this is uh
I'm calling it hateful eight meets free
fire because what's wrong with Jabba the
Hutt he doesn't move it's hard to do a
job of the hunt movie with a protagonist
when that doesn't that doesn't go
anywhere I mean he moved a little bit
back in the day but Hut's in general I
mean they're giant slightly slow okay
fine are you picking the new the Jedi
Java or its special edition Java
probably like special edition especially
slowly okay yeah I don't mean to use
special edition as a as a slur but uh
yeah he's mobile okay he's mobile okay
you got a whole bunch of outer-rim bad
guys I gotta meet in one room to
negotiate some spice trades or somesuch
and they're all scheming against each
other most of these guys aren't gonna
get out of here alive who's there Ziro
the Hutt and his brother Jabba also
known as Jabba digital inject ear
his real name thanks Wikipedia well I
just want to do a cool hateful eight
with some of like your favorite Cantina
dudes and some of your favorite
mercenaries you know Boba Fett's there
this is a great way to introduce dr.
Aphra who's a really popular she's kind
of like an evil Indiana Jones but for
Star Wars throwing nice doodles
CAD Bane grito salacious crumb all your
favorite Jon Schnepp Star Wars
supporting characters in what you keep
them in one room it's a it's a crime
suspense flick it's all these guys
double crossing each other and triple
crossing each other and it's a powder
keg waiting to explode this is the first
time Jabba really steps up and becomes
the ruthless gangster we all know today
how by the way Joe you lost me it's nice
noodles
I found myself it's not sighs dude
there's where you and I part ways my
friend mine is called Jabba the Hutt
fallen angel Jabba is studying in this
film to become more or less young Jabba
he's studying to become basically a
space rabbi I'm he's studying like a
kind of a space version of the top of
the towel mood if you will and he wants
to follow in his father's footsteps
but there are mercenaries there are
villains who come into his father's
space dry cleaners and shake him down
and and take money and demand payment
and then one time Jabba's father doesn't
have the money and young little he
looked young Jabba looks a little bit
like a sperm like a single like a little
like a little sperm okay maybe it looks
like Robin from the Muppets sure he sees
his father get murdered and he realizes
that he can't stick with his rabbinical
studies he needs to exact revenge for
the cold-blooded murder of his father
and he goes to his mother because his
mother gets a call from his rabbinical
school and Jabba you haven't been going
to school you haven't been going to your
studies and he's like I've been learning
to fight I've been involved in getting
revenge for our father so he begins
working with mercenaries he goes to the
dark side and he exacts revenge becomes
immersed in that world of mercs and
pay-for-play who and he rises apparently
as a sperm and a launder nests as
sorry your eyes trying to make sure I
clear under rises to the top of the
criminal world all right three wonderful
pitches Jabba the Hutt fallen out guys
what do you well I'm at first what I
heard was basically just Martin Landau's
backstory and rounders so it really
didn't excite me and I wasn't excited
about this at all as a laundromat he's
going to rabbinical school I don't see
any intrigue at all everything taking
place in one room this is Star Wars I
need to see the whole galaxy I see him
intersect all these cool characters and
storylines intersect like saying
salacious criminals be great but in one
room I get bored out of my sickle mine I
want to see him fly around and see it
slowly start to build and how they cross
paths again like better call Saul like
oh there's that one gangster oh my god
where did he come from and where it's
his Baxter and each person then you get
a window into their backstory all these
fantastic characters in the Star Wars
universe
none of them going to rabbinical school
aha base for a Bennigan's of it right so
obviously Judaism has jumped galaxies
sure but that's the thing like it's it's
the Star Wars universe and what a great
way to go off into all these side
stories and figure out all these
backstories of all these fantastic
characters and that's what that's what
I'm gonna make you know when it's not a
terrible idea but you you said you're
gonna put it in three movies you're
gonna hobbit this this job of the higher
but you're gonna hop in a movie about
Jabba slowly gaining weight like you
know what I don't need any more in Star
Wars origin movies I don't need a hey
what was that guy's backstory like let's
find out because it's never good and I
don't care I don't care how they built
the Death Star I don't care about how
Han Solo gets his vest I just want to
see a cool movie with Star Wars
characters that's why my movie it's not
an origin story it's just a cool earlier
Jabba story with a bunch of criminals
double-crossing each other you bring in
a guy like Jeremy Sonier who did green
room to do it
it'll just be intense it'll be really
violent it's not gonna worry about like
oh man member member how
Chuey remember I'm not talking about
that job impediment boba fett in Hebrew
school like that but none of those
things sound interested me I don't care
about a job of origin I I just care that
he's Jabba the Hutt why are you making
this movie no were asked to hold a
gunpoint to do so I just care that he's
Jabba the Hutt I don't care how we got
there I have some canonical issues with
yours because he's from a family of
gangsters man he didn't go to Hebrew
school he's from a family of gangsters
his grandparents Joe gets the point
that's kind of filed waiting yeah one
room three movies alright I pictured a
franchise I'm pitching spin-offs I'm
pitching Burger King MOG show that's 70%
of the fan page and the one that I think
everyone agreed that these are all bad
the Pudu sorry Jose was the one I
probably would watch I don't want to see
three movies of him losing weight and I
don't want to see him rabbis thanks
rabbi school funny but I think scum and
villainy cool title all right we got to
get on a nap characters sold let's go to
our start yeah what do they say 90%
yeah 70% yet the YouTube vote is going
to Joe and that's yeah it's pretty
pretty easy win for Joe there I did see
a name scroll by for an alt name Joe if
you can't get scum and villainy which
was the hut full eight
that's good I like that helpful a potful
eight someone make a poster here we go
round four now guys did you know it's
the 10-year anniversary of super bad we
wanted to ask fun question lon kudos I
think it was LAN right what super bad
actor has gone on to have the best
career at first I was like hmm but then
you go and look at the who's in this
movie everyone was in this movie so I
want to know who had the best career in
it since 10 years later of super bad Joe
who you thicken well the guy that picked
marc maron to play the Joker is gonna
make a weird choice I'm going Bill Hader
I think Bill Hader hit the ground
running after super bad and has never
stopped he is Bill Hader is under the
radar one of the most influential voices
in modern American comedy he has either
written on so many major prod projects
voiced them been in them whether it's a
supporting role in like a forgetting
sarah marshall or if it's a leading role
in trainwreck he's written on South Park
he wrote he was a script doctor on
inside out Bill Hader is just he's all
over the place he carried SNL for like
eight years and a lot of it just leads
out of super bad I think he's definitely
had the best career out of any of these
folks some of them might have had bigger
careers but Bill hader's is is the best
he he's in this cool position where
anything that's good that he's in people
look at Bill Hader and they go this was
elevated by Bill Hader and anything bad
that bill hit has ever been in people go
Bill Hader couldn't even save this thing
and he's just he's Teflon he can do no
wrong and that's I mean you can't buy a
career in a reputation like that alright
how well I agree that that is a
veritable who's who of today's Hollywood
icons all at the height of their powers
but it's Emma Stone clearly you have a
lot of solid comedy guys all over the
movie and like there and like a goddamn
dog fights crumb all on equal footing
but Emma Stone is
number one actress in Hollywood today
also she won an Oscar and she's among
the highest paid actresses she can play
any type of role you throw at her she
can sing and dance if you want her to
Emma Stone is by far has gone on for the
best to the best career okay so you said
best career and that's why some of the
things I like both these but you're
right house right this is this is a
fantastic cast to pick from it was hard
for me to find a person there's a lot
about Bill Hader and Emma Stone that I
like but if you talk about best career I
have to go Seth Rogen because first of
all look what he's he's had a
diversified career in the sense that
he's written on currently on preacher so
that that's exciting to me and also he
did the voice of Kung Fu Panda the first
the first Kung Fu Panda is it great it's
not just a great family and kids movie
it teaches that it has the teachings of
kung fu not to mention a movie like 50
50 50 50 was not just wacky comedy he
can do the dick jokes and all that stuff
but 50/50 is a heartfelt movie about
what it would be like if you or your
best friend is going through cancer and
how to react it was such a heartfelt
amazing movie that he did so on top of
the obvious choices of all of the funny
stuff that he's done I really go for
best career as a writer and a director
and an actor he's doing stuff that I'm
intrigued to watch and I mean I'm
anxious to see even more of what he's
gonna bring to the table all right fan
it out guys what I like so much about
Bill Hader is he can he can do these he
can do these bigger projects and then he
can go and just do these small passion
projects you know he can do a big movie
but then he can go do a season of human
giant with like Aziz Ansari and Paul
Scheer or he can do a documentary now he
then he goes back up but he does big
things South Park he does venture
brothers season people he's a voice on
Bob's Burgers he's in everything and you
know you talk about Kung Fu Panda Kung
Fu Panda is a great movie but I mean
Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs is
probably again under the radar which is
I think he's it's such an underrated
movie it's such a funny animated
and that is largely because of Bill
hader's performance and the stone has
had a big career it's very big but I
think when you are put on a bigger
pedestal your your fails are Feiler and
your and your falls you fall harder you
know you do you that's when you run into
your Aloha's and that's move that's when
you know she's in la-la land is she
great I would argue maybe not I think
maybe even Bill Hader can sing and dance
better than her based on some of his
work on SNL but yeah I mean this is the
dude as a table full of comedians you
know I wish I could do one Stefon
you know but this guy's got stuff on
he's a South Park guy he was in trop
he's one of the funnier parts of Tropic
Thunder he's great in Adventureland and
he's proven with a train wreck that he
can also carry a movie as a male
romantic lead and I think I thought it
was the Virginia's part of trainwreck I
think he proved that he's not the guy to
be the leading man in a film in
trainwreck well even if he's not gonna
be at the old-time great leading man he
can still do it and look at everything
that he has to fall back well here's the
thing I did the points you're making
about Bill Hader are the reasons why I
go seth rogen because you look about he
played Steve Wozniak in the Steve Jobs
movie he's not being wacky comedy he's
any that's a heartfelt intense movie and
it's about people he's playing an actual
person that is so hard to do
and the stone good in la-la-land I liked
it but and I think she did to find out I
feel like there's a bunch of other
actresses that could have done that part
and I feel a safe Logan is doing stuff
that other people can't do you guys are
going tit for tat this guy wrote for
this this guy did the voice of this this
guy did this Seth Rogen also made
sausage party which was a terrible these
guys have both had misfires they've both
stumbled emma stone Kosciuszko i
completely disagree with you about
trainwreck but emma stone has risen to
be the number one actress in Hollywood
you guys are coming after each other
within this this escapologist comedy
guys this is a box office I mean I mean
so what I mean
car dad's make like atomy award-winner
box office and a catted but i will not
subside like you can like any argument
you make can not leapfrog over those
elements but that's the Collingwood over
Aloha yeah that movie is a goddamn
affront to Hawaii and that you got to
take that up with Cameron Crowe for
casting her and that was yeah that was a
misfire the thing about a career like
Emma Stone's is that the moment she has
and they're coming because when you're
up top everyone just wants to see you
fall in the moment she has something
that doesn't do so well the front page
of every trade or whatever is gonna be
like there's Emma Stone finally screws
you just painted a what-if scenario and
what if samus never seth rogen did Green
Hornet which sucked and he came back
from that he came back with 50/50 he's
run come back and done these amazing
voices he's like I said and and come few
Panda Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs
as a fine kid movie Kung Fu Panda is
teaching on a high spiritual Buddhist
level which is important and so I think
that's why he's transcending all of this
Hollywood stuff but I would say even I
you know in sort of this hater Rogan
comparison I think people still go to
Seth Rogen for very specific things I
think people have still put a sort of a
Seth Rogen box around stuff - Seth Rogen
whereas with hater you know funny rider
funny sketch guy a decent decent took
great actor I mean he's bb-8 you know
he's the voice of bb-8 he's everywhere
people can go to Bill Hader for pretty
much anything and he'll deliver that's
such I mean that's that's a smart career
that's a secure career I mean this guy's
a utility player and there's absolutely
nothing wrong with that because you need
that dude he's directed one episode of
TV the show Barry he can't he I haven't
seen him direct so I can't sit there and
say he's better than Seth Rogen Seth
Rogen's already proven he can direct and
he has white aspect of his career right
but we're talking about best career
that's the question then Seth Rogen has
a more well-rounded career and he's had
success as a director a writer and an
actor alright using as your final
thoughts how final thoughts why Emma
Stone over these two I've heard a lot
they've been fine and said she was bad
in a little ha but yeah give me more to
stand up on with Emma Stone
yeah I mean you're talking about a
bigger Hollywood issue in regards to
Aloha
that is you know Hollywood makes
tone-deaf choices as far as racial
casting sometimes we we've all seen it
in numerous times but her performances
the quality of her acting she's been in
superhero films she's been in smaller
films she's been in independent films
she's been in real tearjerker like films
that just like wrench your heart out and
she has proven herself across the board
as an actor she's Academy Award winner
she's and she is like if you're gonna
she's one of the two top actresses in
all of Hollywood today if you were going
to cast someone worldwide to put asses
in seats it is Emma Stone
like it's just Emma Stone and Jennifer
Lawrence those are only there's only two
I could think of right now at the very
top of the mountain best career it is
Emma Stone these guys have had great
careers yeah no doubt but why are they
better than Jonah Hill I mean McLovin is
right on their heels then Emma Stone
Emma Stone is peerless in this category
Joe I think Bill hader's career will
never slow down will never end like
Russell Crowe used to be at the top of
the mountain in Hollywood and now
Russell Crowe is throwing phones and
drinking beer under the mountain whereas
a utility guy like Bill Hader he's gonna
be around forever he delivers on
everything he does I mean I would argue
on just eight years of caring Saturday
Night Live alone people tuned in for
Stefan he's the O and weirdly Stefan had
like a better emotional arc than some of
the characters he hasn't played like he
ended miring Seth Meyers is very
emotional but then you've got you know
Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs you've
got him on South Park Venture Brothers
these comedy institutions and then he
can still go back and do you know
smaller series on Funny or Die and stuff
like that because he's a chameleon he's
not above anything he's not below
anything he just brings quality to
everything he does this guy's gonna be
around forever
damn oh yes well how I have to say you
you are gonna have to look out for the
sausage party mafia because your your
derision of that film has well say that
movie was was a pretty well reviewed by
heretics and fans they're hot and brown
around a lot of people not happy and I
was disappointed by it the majority of
the conversation I believe a little
confusion surrounding Graham's choice
people thinking that you got Seth Rogen
confused with Jack Black
Seth Rogen is in the Kung Fu Panda
movies does it voice Panda this Jack
like a Seth Rogen is mantis so there's a
lot of people that are a small part yeah
oh yeah right except eople think I don't
know if ya actually said the people
think you conflated them so yes Seth
Rogen that the pan became right it yes I
mean just yeah I knew that but thank you
very much
yeah look at at the pole I could declare
a winner here but Andy I'll defer to
your judgment well I'm having trouble
because I think it's time between two I
think um I just didn't hear enough
things beyond just she's a good actress
and won the awards in EMA whereas with
Bill Hader it's a strange well it's not
as popular like the his his range his
range of writing inside out and South
and working at South Park and SNL and
the movies from supporting - it was all
very actually strong argument if he's
that sort of smart secure utility player
that I think actually was a strong
argument and then Graham I think you
also brought that by just pointing out
not only the funny and preacher and all
the things but he really he can write
you can direct he can also star which is
to me what you said is a well-rounded
career the question is best career is
between those two between Bill and Seth
and I'm torn dan did you have any
outlier thoughts to help me here between
those two yeah bill it's F excellent
adventure
hmm I said man I was kiddin with
something else about being honest oh my
god yeah I think if I had to from what
I've listened to I think that Joe may
have made it more compelling argument
for well-rounded career but I think
Graham was also pretty strong and
pointing out his directorial he does
have the directorial yeah that's why I'm
torn so that didn't help thanks sorry
they were doing you were working I won
it's my job to judge yeah Seth Rogen
voice I gotta say four of having the
Aloha knock I'll give it to Joe looking
at the points here it was torn for me
but then you were the one who brought up
Aloha so Joe gets the point
oh just Wow Joe takes a lead do you even
see I don't so Graham wow you need this
point to tie Graham to make it in the
finals gotcha
Joe you have made it in the finals Joe
it's on fire this today's Twitter
youtuber on fire because they both
picked Emma Stone what that round Emma
Stone took 41% of the YouTube boat to
look I love Emma Skye sorry I just
didn't hear the near more than she's axe
well yeah no exactly today but I wish
she would just shouted eza over and over
again it was close wow you're still in
this though alright
question five which of Marvel's
defenders would make the best standalone
film now we're offering something
interesting here if you pitch us an Iron
Fist movie starring Finn Jones I will
give you double points because we all
agree that's a handicap yes Dan we
agreed collectively as producers that if
you took on the task of pitching an Iron
Fist movie with Finn Jones then yes if
you managed do you want to go there and
pitch us what your movie is with him and
then I will give you double points
you'll get two points so Hal Graham
you're still in this Joe you're a friend
I'm sorry Hal you're a first what are
you gonna wish defender would you turn
into a standalone film oh it would
absolutely be daredevil yeah I'm not
even gonna try to defend the shit-heap
that is iron pheasant
let's hear em all yeah I got gram mine
actually is Iron Fist okay Joe I'm iron
fisting as well just so you know you're
up against two iron fist go ahead gotcha
oh man double fisted yep
daredevil opened up the the Marvel
Universe on Netflix and it got everyone
excited and I think we can all agree it
hasn't quite lived up to the high note
hit by daredevil thus far the best
moments throughout Netflix's Marvel
Marvel's Netflix run have been from
daredevil the action has been the best
that hallway fight scene in the first
season introducing Punisher in the
second season his cast of characters his
side job him being a lawyer there was
the most compelling stuff to navigate in
this series and it would transition best
to film because the two the two seasons
of daredevil have been the two best
seasons of Marvel Netflix television I
mean that is all the almost all the
proof that I need that this would be the
best franchise the best character to
translate into a cinematic universe all
right grandma Tara your take on Iron
Fist is the reason I would do Iron Fist
is because the challenge everyone would
be like wow Iron Fist is the weakest of
the Netflix ones Finn Jones not a good
actor and so how do you do this I wanna
be like how do you do this it would be
the when I saw the first trailer for
Batman Begins and I went oh god they've
ruined Batman so many times good luck
[ __ ] and Christopher Nolan came in
and knocked it out of the park and made
three of the best Batman movies that are
that will ever have been made that's how
I would go into this because the
mistakes that they made in Iron Fist is
one he's not a great martial artist okay
the the the Finn Jones he's not a good
martial artists all the other actors
they've cast and all the other they're
good fighters they're good martial
artists so what I would do
as I would focus on his sidekick played
by a Colleen wing played by Jessica Han
wick right she's amazing she is an
amazing martial artist I would focus
more on her and I would focus more on
the lineage of the immortal iron fist
and and the story of again I'm a huge
I'm a huge backstory guy I love learning
more about people I want to know more
about how he came up I want to know more
about the hand and I would focus the
iron fist story on that and so the
action scenes would have more of her
fighting and I would also bring in some
really good fight choreographers really
some of the best because I feel like the
one that's the one Netflix show where
they like that maybe we cut the fight
choreography budget or something like
that so I would put a lot of money into
fight choreography and I would come up
with really inventive ways to tell his
backstory and I would focus so much on
her and then I would also focus on his
relationship with Luke Cage because I
grew up reading Power Man and Iron Fist
and that's what I want to know about
okay Joe what are you doing this is a
Iron Fist starring Finn Jones you guys
know what I didn't like iron fist
starring Finn Jones nobody liked it he's
not a good actor he was even the
character was written horribly like
there's no way you can like this
character like I feel so sad because I
quit my one job and a bunch of people
died as a result and I'm just gonna cry
on my jet like he's he's awful like they
made the defenders about how awfully is
but that wasn't enough so I want to give
the world what they want and I want to
give Finn Jones's Iron Fist basically
his own revenant movie not just plot
wise where Iron Fist is just slowly
dying in the wilderness and has to do
horrible things to survive but I
literally want in eure to to do this
movie with him throw him in the actual
wilderness make him eat bison hearts and
actually break this man in character and
character so that we all get the
retribution that we deserve after having
one of my favorite Marvel characters
completely ruined for me this is just
Iron Fist out in the wilderness
suffering and hopefully he becomes a
better person because of it I would get
bored by that after a while because how
many feet obviously starting fires with
his with his Chi hand and I'd be like
all right
I really think that while I understand
your revenge that you want that revenge
Joe
I actually think because I agree with
you it's a fantastic character and every
time they screw up a comic book
character it's when they abandon the
goddamn comic book and then hire people
that don't know what they're doing which
is so mind-boggling considering
considering this and I think daredevil
yeah I like it
but I've already seen all of Daredevils
greatness in Netflix no no we haven't
actually there is so much we could
explore in regards to his relationship
with stick and Elektra man that
backstory is a treasure trove I'm just
like I'm salivating thinking of it in
defenders they're already going through
stick and an Electra and defender stick
out his hand cut off and she's a zombie
I mean like why do I need that in a
movie because we haven't had their
medical school yes it's a nunnery so no
no rabbinical school they're only
touching upon it we could have a deep
dive into this one character who is the
most compelling character and there's so
much to explore I mean how daredevil
learned to see using all of his other
senses how amazing is that
that in the first season of on Netflix I
don't need to see that again it's it's
great I love the first I love the
daredevil but I've already got a taste
of it and we see how he operates but
really seeing that experience and
learning from Scott Glenn who is an
amazing one of the best side actors not
to help here just can't tell me how cuz
I sort of related what you're saying to
help but tell me how this movie is gonna
be different from what we've seen and
why it's gonna be better we know
something with iron fists that are iron
something with daredevil that we also
haven't seen is you know he's a he's an
amazing Acrobat he Spidey swings without
the webs and that that would be a cool
thing to see in the movie but
let's get back to how much I want to see
Finn Jones suffer in the Arctic with mr.
Harris to put the camera on him this is
the movie everyone wants like people are
avenged poor people oh man people line
up to see Finn Jones have to go through
this and eat a heart you both prefaced
your arguments by saying here's crap
that I hate now let's give people more
of it yes you did also cheating and
you're making a calling wing movie I saw
you do that I'm making a Finn Jones iron
fist yes but so what that's my that's my
sleight of hand because young Jonas is
out just a long boring slog this
daredevil would be different
because we we could see those moments
where he came into his own we can
explore is Emma going more orogeny store
yeah more money that we have enough see
a lot of his origin in the first season
no they have not done a deep dive into
it so you want to go deeper and more
specifics yes family flipping around and
being crazier big-budget daredevil out
in the woods you know eating his own
urine fighting a bear then just rehash
the Netflix it's not rehashing because
in the Netflix show also stick left
daredevil once daredevil started to care
for him as a father figure and it we
were kind of left what happened in that
period when daredevil had to was left to
his own devices I got all that because
again it's a testament to how good the
Netflix series is like I would be like
okay if I saw a trailer for this film I
and put all those things you put in
there I go yeah I know I saw this Scott
Glenn's great I got it now like I would
like I want to see we can actually you
know make it cause I have I do I admit
that sleight of hand openly because
that's the character I care abouts if
I'm stuck within then I then she's the
one I want to go in if you want to see
now you know
yes house movie would probably also give
us more Vincent D'Onofrio kingpin and
that would be amazing but let's get back
to just hurting Finn Jones I just yeah
this character not only is this fun for
me but this character just needs to be
broken because there's nothing redeeming
about him at the end of defender sorry
spoilers I don't know okay end of my
statement pal
yeah so uh Joe pitched just an
unwatchable three-hour epic and Graham
pitched a movie starring a tertiary
character not Finn Jones if it's a good
movie it's a good movie but this film it
would be a particular weed following
episodes of his life we'd see him being
raised by stick we'd see things that
weren't included in obviously it's gonna
be different than the Netflix show and
him learning to use these powers and
again what we didn't see in that first
season of daredevil is the period
between when stick left him and when he
went to college how did he matriculate
how did he become a hero
how did he hone his skills or board in
that you're good you're good you're good
you're good you got it how you gave me
just I just I don't I don't know what
your movie is it sounds like an episode
where we just get an elongated stick
story
no that's daredevil goes on spring yeah
I don't know I just I there so Jeff
world and you just sort of I did some
fried confused why you would go back and
fill in little holes with and nothing
exciting just but thoughtful but so I'm
a little torn of what what do we see Joe
with you admitted you're out of this you
said yeah went on the long boring slug
so it came down to Graham but Graham did
cheat he didn't used Finn Jones that
said he did make a very good movie so
I'm not gonna give you double points but
I'm gonna give you one point cuz I think
you pitched the best movie
dan but you technically didn't pitch a
movie starring Finn Jones so I'm not
awarding you double points does that
seem fair damn come on Dan
well I actually I probably would have
given it to Jo because I think that the
double points was a reward for including
iron fists like that's the whole reason
get the double points so by excluding at
you you have not best are in the double
jounin win though Jonjo pitched a
terrible movie that not wouldn't revenge
porn that's gram thoughtfully called it
out it was so much for me that Joe won
it would be the grameen house if I could
exactly torture or see something we've
seen already I'd rather watch Colleen
wing that's how I'd deem it Dan go ahead
what else love it alright so there you
go Graeme mate with two points Joe you
if you had one you would have gotten
double points because you did give us
what we asked for but I did not want to
see that tallow fantastic job will you
help me now yes and this last round now
you get to put your judging hat back on
you know how the rules work here five
more points to win this game you'll have
20 seconds and a 10-second rebuttal
anyone have any questions
it's been a while since I've been on can
you just a quite sure yeah well I will
ask you a question if you both say the
same answer at the same time it's
whoever said it first okay if you say
the same answer you'll have to pick a
different answer if Joe sat at first
you'll have 20 seconds I'll remind you
as we do it 20 seconds to speak and then
Joe off 20 seconds speak then you'll
have a 10-second rebuttal and then
whoever answers first goes first make
sense yes I will walk you through as we
do it here we go let's do a gram let's
do it buddy
number one speed round best fantasy
movie that's not set in middle-earth How
to Train Your Dragon 2 Excalibur ok Joe
and Graham I heard Joe first with how to
train a dragon part to go ahead and
xcalibur for Graham it Joe your first 20
seconds on the clock down yeah
go ahead when you're ready the first
moment that made me realize how to train
your dragon to was gonna be fantastic is
that the characters have aged they've
evolved this isn't just gonna be a
franchise where they're all 10 years old
forever it's a it's a movie about both
these characters stepping into adulthood
hiccup and the dragon meeting his mom
the reveal it the the visuals the reveal
of his mother is so incredible his
Excalibur's fantastic it came out in
1981 John Boorman directed it it is an
epic crazy piece there is sex love
violence it is the best telling of the
King Arthur story that I have ever seen
and it is something that I would
consider everybody to go back to and
masterpiece it is top 100 a f5 film
watch this movie it's fantastic
Excalibur is so hokey it's almost
unwatchable I'd rather watch Guy
Ritchie's King Arthur instead How to
Train Your Dragon is gorgeous the the
action sequences are big just the flight
sequence at the beginning alone How to
Train Your Dragon is a fine kids movie
but it is not this masterpiece that is
visually stunning it is great for kids I
want to rank a dragon well I want to
pull the sword out of a rock and fight
how what do you think of those arguments
that was really rough they both came out
of the gates gun blitt guns blazing but
in the end I I was more taken aback by
Graham's argument I'd go with Graham Dan
yeah I just listening circular to the
arguments Joe sold me on a lot of things
that I didn't understand was much of
names that I didn't get hiccup and I
don't know who those people are Graham
was I mean he was telling me a great
movie about swords and everything and so
yeah I guy what was gravel is it really
in the top of AFI 100 no that was a lie
no but I figure it was like he is he
would put your you would put it in there
okay yeah well I do know the movie Joe
and I do it that you actually I know
it's not my favorite of the two I'd like
them both a lot though but you reminded
me it is of the continuation of the age
is very great but I stood here and you
just call Excalibur jump yeah
we're back from Grandma's wrapping us up
I agree with them two to one any weight
so grab you at first play all right note
to self don't just call it dumb there we
go
and I don't have Terminator 3d what to D
movie should get a 3d re-release Star
Wars a new hope that's in the Furious
Tokyo Drift
ochio Drift that didn't come out in
three days yeah and I don't think so
wait what was the question which to deny
which 2d movie should get a 3d
re-release okay got ya don't think that
wasn't 3d that was pre avatar yes bad 3d
but not for that yes okay I Star Wars
new hope go ahead grin when you're ready
20 seconds
Star Wars a new hope fantastic movie the
hyper warp drive all the special effects
that keep that were there when the movie
came out in 77 now I get it in 3d I get
layering I'm out in space like gravity
it will make that classic story even
better for new audiences and for people
that have been have watched it when they
were a kid like me
Star Wars new hope 3d Joe that sounds a
lot like a special edition buddy stop
messing with my Star Wars fast and
furious Tokyo Drift would benefit so
much from this release because it's
already so weird and bonkers the car
races would look awesome in 3d little
bow-wow mugging to the camera in 3d come
on this movie already has a huge cult
following and I think people would come
out to see this it's so weird and bright
and colorful and you know at just Tokyo
and 3d yeah I don't need to see Vin
Diesel and family in 3d I don't need it
I'll seen all the Fast and Furious
movies a million times Star Wars here's
a way to take a classic movie and make
it better
[Music]
Vin Jones is an in Tokyo Drift until the
very end you're talking about a special
edition you can't improve Star Wars a
new hope dude it doesn't need the 3d
it's perfect the way it is whereas this
movie would be massively improved I can
I just say that neither Vin Diesel until
the very end offend Jones is definitely
not it
Jones in the brain because you really
don't like him yeah you want to run over
I'll go first this round and then
justice will pop up I thought uh yeah
this actually surprisingly Joe gave me
an interesting and the special edition
counterpunch was strong for me you
called you'd make it Star Wars better
which scares me which I feel like you
even then jumped on us it's already
perfect or as Tokyo Drift is terrible
and seeing little bow-wow mug the three
team might be kind of amusing so I'm
gonna go Joe dan what are you thinking
this time I grab all the way Graham Wow
oh I agreed with you with all those like
you like get out of my brain because I
was thinking most of those same things I
go with Joe okay we went with the more
fun don't touch our Star Wars any more
leave it alone I ran out of time but
that's why honest trailers was created
it was in 3d alright joke is the point
all right number three who should direct
bad boys 3 if Michael Bay doesn't know
Michael Bay who should direct bad boys 3
Edgar Wright
joestar Oh
Jeong woo grab you first yes sir
Michael Bay is one of the worst
directors that has ever lived on the
face of the earth he's a special effects
guy that should just be doing trailers
Edgar Wright could take this and make it
fantastic he could revive this franchise
he knows how to direct this exact type
of movie better Michael Bay can't direct
himself out of a wet paper bag Edgar
Wright would make this film and this
franchise and making me want to go what
was the question just clarification what
who should direct bad boys three if
Michael Bay doesn't got it Edgar Wright
can make an Edgar Wright movie I don't
see Will Smith and Edgar Wright sitting
down and Edgar Wright being like
storyboards and Will Smith being like
sure dude whereas John Woo knows how to
work with movie stars of that caliber he
can deliver this action movie you want
dual wielding you want Mexican standoff
you want doves that's what I want my bad
boys movie not a clever soundtrack and
weird Michael Cera jokes Edgar Wright
just directed Kevin Spacey and Jon Hamm
he knows how to do a list actors and
guess what Will Smith would kill for the
chance to work with Edgar Wright John
Woo has just done this all over we would
get the movie in a new take they were in
an Edgar Wright arthouse film bad boys 3
is boom popcorn that's John Woo that's a
Tom Cruise going up a motorcycle off a
hill well limp Biskit plays that's what
John was gonna give to a bad boy siku
wow that was a interesting back and
forth for me Dan now I'm gonna go to you
this time first it's gonna pick John Woo
examples why do you just pick the worst
thing because we're making a bad boy z2
is a horrible movie you brought that
into your argue it not me I'm going
Edgar right pal also Graham Graham okay
it was interesting cuz you did you've
sold me actually I want another chick
leverage but then you came back with
always worked with amazing a-listers
like Jon Hamm but then you did the fact
that you will would kill to work with
him it was another one of that's
probably true so even though I was torn
I think yes Graham
ended up
back in the end so Graham gets point all
right contest my friend improve any
movie in honor of the Knight Rider movie
and prove any movie by adding a talking
car
Brooklyn sirs-e Ronan yeah I think they
did yeah um
interstellar okay
cram your person cook 'ln is a boarding
overrated film and I would love to see a
Model T come up and go we gotta get out
of House kitchen way Davidson they jump
on it and everyone goes to the ball yeah
might that's what make this movie
fantastic
all right I doesn't even need the rest
of time Joe interstellar talking car I
just don't think the technology was
there yet for a talking car whereas an
interstellar interstellar needed to take
itself a little less seriously and if
George Clooney's robot had been a
talking car that everybody gets in and
zips around it would have made the movie
so much more fun you could have had the
intellectual Chris Nolan ISM but with a
fun talking car voiced by a wacky gorge
Clooney I just think it would have been
elevated the film it would have let it
breathe a little bit first of all please
argue a movie you know who's actually
interstellar does not that's gravity
you're thinking of friends so I'm
talking charting phony voices a robot an
interstellar cars no I don't know as his
tars but I don't think I know he'd voice
tag a dog and some [ __ ] about the
interstellar void
don't put your mistakes on me Joe boy
stur over the night George Clooney yeah
you got lost in there you gotta get a
girl with gotta give that to graham
pillar with George Clooney yeah we
should also tars is sort of a talking
car grandpa set point we still need to
do one more Joey need to get this to
illicit a time to force a tiebreaker but
that was fun to listen to I didn't want
to correct you during oh here we go
how many name two actors tell me which
one's better I always thought it was
Clooney it's so weird oh well Steve
Carell or Will Ferrell it's deep grill
Will Ferrell
go ahead grin when you're ready Steve
Carell if you first you look at where he
started 40 year old virgin he's
fantastic of that and look to who he is
now the big short he that is not a
comedy he's not doing wacky Steve Carell
ISM he is showing his depth and strength
as an actor and we know he can do the
wacky stuff we know he can do the office
and whatever else but the big short is
where you really start to see who Steve
Carell is is an amazing actor and he's
gonna win awards Joe Will Ferrell has
also delivered serious performances yeah
I mean even just the end the the dad and
lego movie is is so impactful in just
such a small amount of screen time and
his highs are so much higher as a
comedian than Steve Carell I mean just
anchorman Talladega Nights the SNL I
mean he's a he's a stronger comedic
presence and he can do the dramatic work
just as well
when Ferrell while very funny kind of
only has one note and when he's trying
to be serious he always looks like an
actor that's about to start laughing
where Steve Carell is living that part
again I asked you to watch the big short
I think Steve Carell roles are also very
similar the office and and brick are
kind of similar honestly whereas Will
Ferrell has range he's got the roles
you've got the star power a funny writer
funny performer Hamlin alright and house
one brick as my recollection
with Jillian talking about how this is
this one that was a little that was a
nice ping-pong yeah it's a toughy but at
the at the end of the day what grabbed
you what argument Graham's argument okay
yeah
which do you have a part so I mean the
range yeah the the big short and and
when he said that will Ferrell seems
like he's on the verge of breaking
that's what I think of I don't think
like what will I've seen Will Ferrell
serious roles and just Graham just like
kind of broke it down like brass tacks
for me it's like oh yeah what will
Ferrell you know he did I I don't think
of him being cast I wouldn't want to
cast him in dramatic stuff Steve Carell
has gone above and beyond no one mentss
in Foxcatcher but he was fantastic in
that as well so was kami because they
both kind of at the same point which is
that they're actors they're comedic
actors that are dramatic too and that
was kind of the same thing back then I
thought better comedic actor for Will
Ferrell but better range for grand rel
right so it's like I don't know it's at
hasta I might lean toward Graham a
little bit because he was able to pull
out one role I think that exemplified
why ste girl was better dramatically but
I don't know yeah I was impressed you
pull up the lego movie moment it was a
get a small part that was good but I
it's hard to compete because you did
bring out the office for you did give me
comedy ones while you did I think the
faculty were able to pull out Big Short
gives Graham the edge in the play
[Applause]
for juice star you came from blood
hiring you all are winners here today
congratulations that was so much fun for
real you get the first plug man you won
Graham tell us where to get your pipe
gear your podcast documentary your good
ear buds the podcasting documentary will
be available starting September 12th on
all platforms iTunes Amazon VOD you can
pre-order it on iTunes today so please
check out ear buds the podcasting
documentary directed by myself and work
man Thank You Hal Rudnick yeah he'll
Rudnick Hal Rudnick on instagram you
know I'm blowing up the Graham daily
weekly monthly I see there you blown up
the Graham yeah a lovely happenstance
yeah just hit me up on all social medias
at Hal Rudnick joestar and find me at
Arby's at Joe star 187 and I'm here you
guys know where to find me I'm around
Bravo all three of you thank you for
doing that Dan Merline Merle Dan how's
it going down I have a function I've had
a good show people at home need to learn
what rigged means rig doesn't mean it's
something you didn't like those are two
different words that's not what no fun
show it's good to be back on the couch
and this new dimension of seeing people
react in real time it's a lot of fun
that's something else they're all and I
love that they're having the
conversation they're right here and
that's good as long as you guys are
having that conversation that's what
matters they are ya know everyone's
having a good conversation what seems to
enjoy the show so great thumbs up
alright we'll be back live again
Thursdays 4 p.m. here on YouTube and
don't forget TV fights also on 4 p.m.
Tuesdays over on screen junkies news if
you haven't watched go give Roxy trier
movie TV fights to try and flick bait
Friday is 4 p.m. tomorrow live join us
back here for flick bait we're gonna do
some more fun that's it have a wonderful
of Thursday night we'll see you next
time have a good one bye my prepare
thanks again to t-mobile for sponsoring
today's episode check out what makes
them America's best unlimited network at
t-mobile comm slash coverage
[Music]
you